on l'évoquit à l'instant dans les titres
hélèes c'est un nouveau pavé dans la
marre lancé par nos confrères de
Médiapart oui deux enfants de l'ancienne
directrice du cru de tour aurait
bénéficié de deux chambres en résidence
universitaire malgré la situation
sociale confortable de leurs parents un
avantage indu qui révolte les étudiants
au faible revenus Florent Clavel a tenté
d'en savoir plus regardez c'est toujours
silence radio du côté du cru de tour 24
heures après les révélations de m part
le service communication est tout
simplement injoignable ce que l'on sait
en revanche c'est que les deux enfants
de l'ancienne directrice du clous de
tour ont dû quitter leur logement ce
matin logement dont il profitait depuis
cette rentrée une affaire qui fait tâche
alors que des milliers d'étudiants
peinent à trouver un appartement ou une
chambre dans un marché immobilier
extrêmement tendu rencontré sur le site
des taneur ses étudiantes sont
consternées ça c'est révoltant quand
même qu'on puisse faire ça alors que il
y a beaucoup de gens qui justement ont
éprouvent beaucoup beaucoup de
difficultés pour trouver un logement
c'est réservé aux personnes qui
justement ont besoin de ce genre de
logement qui ont pas beaucoup de moyens
donc forcément s'ils ont les moyens faut
qu'il s'achète un appartement ailleurs
que de prendre la place à des gens qui
en on Besin la question qui se pose
désormais comment le fils et la fille de
Florent salari ont-ils pu obtenir un
logement du CRW et ce en dehors de tout
contrôle on rappelle que ces logements
sont normalement réservés aux étudiants
dont les parents de faible revenus ce
qui n'est pas le cas de Florent salari
et son mari interrogé par miaap le
directeur du cru Alain Cordina se borne
à reconnaître des failles dans la
procédure
d'attribution en revanche le
représentant du set le syndicat étudiant
tourangeau lui n'est pas totalement
surpris par ses révélations également
élu au cru il pointe un manque de
transparence depuis que les étudiants
sont minoritaires dans les instances du
CROUS on sait qu'on ne voit pas tout on
sait qu'on a pas le contrôle sur et
notamment à tour on n' pas forcément une
relation de bonne entente avec tous les
administratifs notamment avec le
directeur du cru directrice de 2019 à
juin 2023 Florent salari est aujourd'hui
secrétaire général au services
départementaux de l'éducation nationale
toujours interrogé par miapart Alain
Cordina affirme qu'une enquête
administrative va être lancée pour faire
la lumière sur d'éventuelles
dysfonctionnement I